[Music]
foreign
here in this video we will discuss the
personalities of all the 10 different
dragons of House of the Dragon each and
every one of them had their own unique
character even though it might not seem
that obvious so let's get to it
the first one air ax this small juvenile
dragon is written by Prince luceris
valerion and was seen in the 10th
episode Iraq's was seen as a feisty
dragon that although was obedient to
lucerys was also Brave and doesn't give
a [ __ ] for danger he was slow to provoke
but when Connor will lash out even at
bigger dragons he may not be the wisest
Dragon but that's mainly because of his
young age and his biological nature to
assert dominance he was around six years
old at that time since all the young
princes had dragons before the final
jump the final time Jump in episode 7
when Eamon finally claimed vegar
the second one Vermax seen first in
episode 6 and again in episode 10 Vermax
had grown and was a sub-adult dragon by
the end of the show vermax's character
was similar to Iraq's but seemed to be
more docile and easy to handle this
dragon as an adult was only seen flying
but when he was small he was seen as a
little boss dragon that required quite a
few Dragon Keepers to handle him he had
already been claimed by jacarus Valerian
by episode 6 and was already around 3
years old at that time therefore by the
end of the season he would have been
around 9 years of age
thirdly Sunfire
he was first seen in episode 7 among
several other dragons and he is written
by aegon Targaryen not much is known
about the personality of this one but as
far as the books say he has a
magnificent and temperamental Dragon one
that has an alpha nature as evident from
him attacking melees with Vega at his
side attacking Greg hoes and Moon Dancer
he is indeed a dragon that is Fit For A
King Sunfire was already around eight to
nine years old at a time of Lena
valarian's funeral and therefore would
have been around 15 years old at the end
of the season
then we have Cyrax Cyrax was bonded to
Queen reneria Targaryen and was first
seen in episode 1 as a smaller type of
dragon this Noble and Valiant state of
the black queen was a she dragon and had
an aura of authority over her as seen
when she could even restrain karaxis
from attacking autohai Tower and the
others during episode 2. Cyrax is
another dragon that is fit for a king or
a queen even though smaller in size than
many of the others she still has an
alpha status to her demeanor the young
she Dragon was born before 104 AC and by
the first episode she would have been
around 10 years of age and therefore by
the end of the season she would be close
to 27 years old
then we have sea smoke C smoke is
written by lenar valarion and was a
white dragon seen first in episode 3.
this dragon is seen as one that is
obedient to his rider and isn't one to
go out of control easily he even follows
melees during their flight to King's
Landing in episode 5. seismo can respect
other dragons and even play second
fiddle to their roles but in times of
War will even attack and challenge
larger more powerful dragons like Verma
Thor sea smoke is also a young dragon
that was bonded to Lena valarion and was
close to or maybe around the same age as
Cyrax around 27 to 28 years old by the
time of the end of the season
next dream fire seen once in episode 5
and again in episode 6 she has princess
Helena targaryen's Dragon dream fire is
mysterious and a bit of a lone wolf even
though she can cooperate or be in the
presence of other people and Dragons but
at times dream fire will lash out at
people that intrude into her private
space and Solitude as seen when she
spewed fire when Eamon Targaryen entered
her lair in the dragon pit this is a she
dragon and was one of the oldest
individuals by 35 AC dream 5 was large
enough for a 12 year old Reina Targaryen
to mount her therefore she would have
been born around 30 AC and her age would
be close to 100 years old by the start
of the war
now we have caraxis the blood worm was
first seen in episode 1 and was born
into Prince Damon Targaryen
temperamental and easy to anger the
dragon Bears a strikingly similar
character trait to Damon himself here's
a dragon that would have been an alpha
if the need arises but most of the time
will let other dragons take charge as
seen in his interaction with Cyrax in
episode 2. although he can attack and
kill as many people as he want which
gives us a hint to his very
temperamental attitude aemon Targaryen
another Eamon from way back in the past
claimed carax is for the first time in
72 AC the dragon Keepers considered him
to be the fiercest of all the young
dragons of the dragonfit and nicknamed
him the blood worm so he would have been
born around 60 BC making him 79 years
old by the end of the season
now we have melees the Red Queen is born
into Princess rainy's Targaryen and was
first seen in episode 5. powerful proud
loyal and a bit reserved melees also
shows a certain set of character traits
that is evident in her writer princess
rhaenys melees is a dragon that takes
charge and leads other dragons in Flight
as seen in episode 5 and episode 10. the
Red Queen was probably one of the older
dragons of the series and would have
been born around 50 to 60 AC goes by 75
AC she was a young dragon and the
fastest Dragon alive
and so by the end of the season she
would have been around 79 to 89 years of
age
the second last among the dragons we
have Verma Thor seen slightly in the
last episode vomitor is yet to be
claimed in the series but later in the
storyline he will be written by a person
named Hugh Hammer vermouth is said to be
a powerful and fearsome Beast he is a
bit lazy to be honest and often curls
with Silver Wing as His companion in
Dragonstone Verma Thor is tolerant of
people and accepting of New Riders which
means that this dragon is kind of a
peaceful and laid-back old person in
nature he was old not as old as Vega but
still very old and was born around 30 AC
thus making him about 100 years of age
and extremely large the third largest
during the dance
lastly vegar seen as the biggest dragon
yet in the series Vega now is currently
bonded to aim and Targaryen the series
Creator and showrunner Ryan Condell
describes vegar as an old old cat as she
is very grumpy and sleeps a lot to add
to this Vega is seen as set in her old
ways who barely listens to her Rider and
was also vengeful as seen when she
basically chopped air ax in half after
the small Dragon smoked her face Vega
was born before the conquest of the
Seven Kingdoms by aegon Targaryen she
was bought in 52 BC and would be around
177 years old by the time the first
season ends when she killed a-rax
so that's it the personalities and the
ages of the different dragon scene in
the show so I hope you have enjoyed
watching this video do hit that like
button for support and subscribe but
most of all smash the Bell icon for
regular updates on new videos right here
on this channel till the next one take
care fam